Speaker 1: Speaking of Trump's followers, Trump
has rebranded his followers MAGA donations in
an all caps, Erratic truth social posts, Throat
Central. Yeah. Trump posting quote We are MAGA
donations. We are very smart. We stick together
as one. We follow truth social truth essential. We
put America first and we will make America great
again. Posting this apropos of nothing just out
there randomly turning on caps lock and posting
this nonsense. Trump giving advice to Fox News
as well. Quote This is in all caps. Fox should
embrace MAGA. Their primetime viewership is down
37% from just a year ago. All because the very
smart, even brilliant MAGA donations know that
despite all the fake lip service. Fox News is
pushing Ron Desanctis or anyone else for that
matter, because they hate the greatest America
first president to ever put on a suit and tie me.
They are all globalists, and globalists will never
make America great again. So going conspiratorial,
completely unhinged, completely off the
rails. And these are the sorts of claims
that I guess his followers are still desperate
for. All of that has been in capital letters,
continuing in capital letters, attacking Alvin
Bragg, prosecutor in New York, saying, quote,
Wow. Legal experts are saying the D.A., Alvin
Bragg, will be immediately forced to drop his
weakened, disparaged case against, quote, Trump
because his top investigator, Jeremy Rosenberg,
corruptly colluded with the disgraced, disbarred
and convicted felon and perjurer in attempting
to frame me with a crime that doesn't even
exist. They apparently became close friends
with lifestyle money, spent a crime. This, on
top of Clinton. Lawyer turned to prosecutors
Mark Pomerantz, illegally writing a book on the
case. This is a former president of the United
States. This is a man who says, elect me again,
give me another four years and I will solve all
of your problems. The very problems I didn't
solve when I was president the first time.
And he wants to do it while claiming everybody
has turned against him. He's the biggest victim
in the world and that he actually won the 2020
election. At a certain point, folks, you know,
I said it earlier, Chris Christie is so obviously
the best Republican candidate running right now,
but the MAGA people don't want him. If the MAGA
people in 2023. Look at who's running. And they
say, Oh, I want Trump. Trump is what makes sense.
I believe Trump. I believe Trump will do the
things he's saying if that's what they believe.
They deserve to get Trump as their nominee and
to lose badly, really badly. The problem is
we can't just look away and assume that Trump
will lose because it's not at all obvious that
Trump will lose. And that's maybe the scariest
part of all of this. After the break, we will
talk about what's going on on the Democratic
primary side. You might be saying what Democratic
primary. We will talk about that after the break.